hello guys welcome to simply learns live
session
today we will discuss what should an
individual learn in the year 2021
let's wait for an ample amount of time
so that few more people can tune in
by the time please allow me to tell you
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies
so if you are the tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon so
that you can never miss an update from
our end
so we have a few more people now hi
everyone
welcome to simply learn so without
further ado
let's get started back in the 2000s
organizations were utterly dependent on
purchase servers
for their it infrastructure these
servers
not only came with limited functionality
but were also
very expensive the traditional way of
storing and managing data
was costly and complicated it required a
massive amount of hardware
and complex software to run all these
issues were resolved using cloud
computing
rather than owning their computing
infrastructures organizations were able
to scale up or scale down resources
based on the requirement companies
providing these computing services
are called as cloud providers according
to c sharp corner
the two popular cloud providers in the
cloud market are
amazon aws and microsoft azure
now let's take a step back and talk
about a question
what should an individual learn in the
year 2021
amazon web services or microsoft azure
though this question is tricky we need
to understand which cloud provider is
the best option to choose
now let's take a brief look at both of
these cloud providers
amazon web services is an evolving cloud
computing platform
that offers various services such as
compute power
storage database content delivery and
other resources to help business
scale and grow aws services are provided
based on a subscription basis
similarly microsoft azure provides a set
of cloud services
to design create and monitor
applications on a network
talking about the general features
amazon web services
was established in the year 2006. today
it holds a market share of 31.7 percent
whereas microsoft azure was started in
the year
2010 and now has a market share up to
16.8 percent amazon aws is the world's
most broadly adopted cloud platform
it offers up to 165 services
globally these services are used by
millions of companies like spotify
netflix facebook bbc etc
talking about netflix the company moved
its id operations to aws in the year
2009.
aws was able to solve the company's
scalability
and data management issues azure offers
several services in various categories
including artificial intelligence
analytics containers iot and many more
these services are used by many famous
companies like accenture
linkedin stack ebay and samsung
accenture chose microsoft azure to boost
productivity
and provide better security to its
employees
the aws pricing model is based on an
hourly basis
with aws every individual pays only for
the services that are required
for his work every person only pays for
the services he consumes
azure pricing is charged on a per minute
basis
the payment system is very simple and
doesn't involve
any long-term contracts microsoft azure
is free of upfront cost and cancellation
fees
and only users pay for the resources
they consume
with azure and amazon aws there are no
additional costs
or termination fees moving on to the
next
factor let's talk about availability
zones
availability zones are isolated data
centers with
independent power and networking these
zones protect
applications and files from data center
failures
in total aws has nearly
77 availability zones within 24
geographic regions
around the world the company plans to
establish
nine more aws availability zones and
three more aws regions in indonesia
japan and spain on the other hand
microsoft azure has many isolated
availability zones
these zones are located within an azure
region and they provide fast network
connectivity
azure has 44 availability zones around
the world
the company is planning to launch 12
more zones
now after discussing the availability
zones let's talk about the services
the services that i am going to compare
here come under the following domains
compute storage database
security and finally networking
aws and azure provide a wide variety of
services
with low migration costs so that every
individual can shift
his or her current traditional
infrastructure to cloud platform
very easily aws ec2 is a suitable
example of compute services
ec2 is a web service that aims to make
life
easier for developers by providing
secure and resizable compute capacity
in the cloud it can be integrated to
several
other services like s3 iam
cloudformation etc azure has a small
service called
azure virtual machine image it helps the
developers
to develop and design identical virtual
machines
in the matter of minutes azure virtual
machines
are becoming more popular among it
infrastructures
these machines let an individual create
and use
virtual machines in the cloud as ias
or infrastructure as a service virtual
machines can be created using azure
portal
as your powershell and arm templates
as your cli or client software
development kits
next comes amazon s3 it is the best
example for storage service
simple storage service is an object
storage service designed to store and
recover
any information from anywhere via the
internet
amazon s3 facilitates storage through a
web service interface
the service provides 99.9 durability and
99.9 availability of objects
it has the capacity of storing computer
files up to
5 terabytes in size on the other hand
azure provides a similar service called
blob storage
service this service provides a large
amount of storage
and is highly scalable it stores an
object in the tires depending on
how often the data is being accessed
blob storage supports
widely used frameworks like java dot net
bison and node.js it is the only cloud
storage service in microsoft azure that
offers a premium
ssd based object storage tire for low
latency networks
aws provides a secure cloud platform
where every individual can manage and
deploy
their applications compared to the
on-premises environment
aws security offers a high level of data
protection
at a lower cost for security purposes
iam is a suitable service aws identity
and access management is a cloud service
that controls and manages aws resources
securely
it has no upfront cost also gives a
facility to create and maintain services
within a specific set of users on your
aws
resources in microsoft azure azure
active directory or in short also called
as azure ad
is a web service which provides mfa
multi-factor authentication features
to users in order to protect their data
from cyber attacks
next is amazon rds it is a web service
designed to simplify the setup operation
and scaling of
a relational database it is simple to
set up
use and scale when required by users
it provides inexpensive and resizable
capacity and
automates several tasks such as hardware
provisioning
database setup batching and backups on
the other side the
azure sql database automatically updates
and backups data
in order to focus on the development of
applications
not just that it also manages database
services and response to client
requirements
client requirements such as scalability
of a service
data backup and high availability of
database
similarly these cloud providers have
plenty of services
that help users build and deploy their
applications effectively
moving on to the next topic let us focus
on integrating aws and azure
with open source tools now we will
explain
how to build a pipeline using jenkins
along with one of the services of amazon
web services
that is the ec2 in this integration
process
we have a sample python application
called as a docker file
this dockerfile will consist of a python
base image
the docker file builds a pipeline in
order to create a docker image upon
pushing the code to the repository later
the new image is used to start a new aws
service on
an ecs cluster now let's have a look at
how the integration of open source tools
happen in azure
in your azure cloud application devops
tools like docker
maven and jenkins can be integrated in
case you want to integrate the jenkins
pipeline
go to project and create a subscription
followed by jenkins
you can specify the required filters
based on your requirement
then choose your endpoint for azure
devops to communicate with
jenkins so that was all about amazon aws
and microsoft azure
both aws and azure are honored to be on
top of
all other cloud providers both provide
all necessary features like scalability
high availability and security
but the moment i hear about choosing the
best one i have to say that all that
depends upon the individual business
needs
both cloud providers are the certified
ones that hold immense value in the
current cloud service market
so this was all about amazon aws versus
microsoft azure
with that we have reached the end of the
session i hope you guys have found this
informative and helpful
thank you for watching and don't forget
to get subscribed to our channel and
stay updated about
more tutorials and live sessions
you